a lot of this is a shack i i said
tonight that
uh you are one of my favorite players
but you don't have what it takes to get
to the next level i set it on purpose i
want you to hear it
what do you have to say about that all
right
that's it that's it all right that's it
okay cool i mean i've been here
i've been hearing that since my rookie
year you know i'm just going to get
better and do what i do
at the end of the day that's what i
wanted to hear you say love your game
brother keep it up appreciate it
yeah i think you know spider-wood i'll
candy conversation you guys are one of
the top
five players but you obviously couldn't
see you playing playing the game
you know you guys are one of the top
five teams in the in in the league
and when the question was like i was
like i asked the panel i was like
can this guy be one of the top five
players in the league and how can he do
it
because these two guys have done it and
the one thing that we were saying is
being able to affect the game in
rebounding
and assist as well as scoring because
each year you become
a more lethal scorer you have each year
and that second way then you'll be
talked about with these guys
with jack and and charles and
lebron's of the world because you're
putting your team in position
with your offensive uh repertoire so
that's the
open conversation that you did not hear
that went on got you